how
fantastic is keanu in his movement he
really looks like he knows martial arts
i know kung fu he rubs him
that's jimmy's uncle oh what let me call
him real quick
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see how
you can get 15
off your next order hey everybody
welcome back to another episode of
stuntman react we are here with amy
johnson stunt woman extraordinaire
kicks punches flips falls that's what i
do
thanks for having me guys nice to be
back it's great to have you back we have
some really cool clips to show you today
one was in the comments the last video i
looked it up and it blew my mind
so amy is going to give us professional
insight into how these stunts were done
what makes them good what could make
them better who knows it's going to be
exciting
let's jump in
[Music]
yeah give him the fingers totally classy
right here i love that
there's a woman in the trunk by the way
what and the guy with his gun
just broke the trunk lever so he needs
to get the woman
out of the trunk of the car wait what oh
my god what a silly
oh this is pretty crazy yeah cars aren't
aerodynamic that's the thing at any
point they can flip and
just hit you and knock you out
[Music]
oh there she is
oh my goodness this was a long fall
how in the world was this shot like they
dropped a car
for real actually they got in trouble
for dropping a car
into like environmentally protected land
[Laughter]
a lot of this was filmed the cadillac
suspended from a helicopter
there's also some blue screen work yeah
but a lot of the stuff is just
actually a car off the ground with the
actors in it going ah
wow i feel like the wide shots that's
legit like that's actually happening 100
and then like you'd punch in i guess to
shoot your close-ups
they did they did some blue screen but
i'm sure they also just did you know
there's a leaf blower
you know they're probably on the ground
right there but in the earlier parts
when he's still falling
you know there's the cameras mounted on
the car you can see the camera starting
to yank the hood
off the front of the car as the thing
seesaws back and forth
well oh that's shady and that's that's a
really good indicator of how dangerous
this actually is
because if that thing flew off and hit
the dude that knocks him out he hits the
ground you know
hold on though if the camera is mounted
and they're like free falling
what happens to the camera in the
footage once it's on the ground
i feel like it hits the ground they get
the shot once it's almost at the ground
another skydiver comes in and he's like
i wonder maybe he checks the film
canister
[Applause]
yo they straight up got burnt up
[Music]
wait what's your name why didn't what
oh and then an extra parachute okay oh
yeah then they had to f
sorry it wasn't it they started to fly
through the windmills
[Laughter]
that was insane that was some uncharted
stuff
seriously yeah love it when you guys
leave comments for cool stunts to react
to
they don't have to be from movies can be
from anything
amy what did you do specifically in this
movie so our coordinator maggie mcdonald
brought
a team in and we basically put together
different choreography
and different styles based off of pen
shocks a lot some
tkd and muay thai for certain characters
i mainly worked with lauren and lauren's
one of my favorite people to work with
i say that working with her is like
butter like kerrygold butter
you know what i mean like grass-fed just
smooth
we came up with a bunch of choreography
and then we performed in front of all
the animators at disney
and in our little mocap suits and then
they used a bunch of our
movements and put it together and made
it beautiful for the day we were just
doing these things
hundreds of times in front of the
animators and then they were like okay
cool
what would it look like if you jumped
down and attacked an enemy and so we'd
jump off a
trampoline give them different poses and
so i was kind of doing pen shocks a lot
style
she was more muay thai so we were
incorporating kicks and
a little bit of trapping so you can kind
of tell the differences
in the styles of martial arts one's a
little more grounded
aggressive fighter and the other one is
a little more flowy more salat
so it's fun to play with different
styles like that
i think with animated fight scenes you
have a lot of opportunity to
work camera angles and really work the
camera in as a participant
a third participant in the fight you
know in real life you have near misses
and you have dodges and things like that
in animation you can take those dodges
and you can make them millimeters away
from hitting
so you can really tighten those things
up i love to see that precision kind of
emphasized and brought to life in
animated fight scenes
i think they did a really good job on
this definitely watch the movie if you
haven't
what are your favorite martial arts
films the first time i was on here i
brought
one of the fight scenes from crouching
tiger hidden dragon that's my all-time
favorite martial arts film
and then also the matrix because it was
just so groundbreaking and it like
brought all these different asian styles
over to the west and we were like whoa
what is this um and it just it just kind
of like changed the trajectory of action
films
we've looked at the dojo fight scene
right in this episode on the show
pull it up
one thing that stands out for me is in
the choreography there's there's
intention behind every move
just like you know you need intention
behind your visual effects or special
effects to make them feel special
you also need intention behind your
choreography because you could just have
fights when somebody's throwing a
thousand punches and somebody's throwing
a thousand blocks up
and you'll get bored in a couple seconds
because you know if you don't intention
you don't tell a story behind it that it
doesn't work
it's like dancing right it's like bop
bop bop
and there's those nice break moments so
that your eyes don't get
exhausted with what's going on i think
people have like a
five to ten second exhaustion rate you
know with their eyes and then they're
just like okay that's too much so this
is just really nice balance but the best
thing for me is that the actors are
doing so much of this
and they trained you know to look good
which is just everything
[Music]
like that kick he did that kick pretty
good
how fantastic is he in his movement
keanu like he
he really looks like he knows martial
arts you know they both do they they're
killing it
when he does that flip you can see him
grab his wires that's the thing he does
multiple times so he does the backflip
he always grabs his wallet
but it hurts so badly if you get those
wires cut like just
right here and they go and you have
bruises and just
a mess so it i totally understand
grabbing never even thought of that you
always assume like oh you're wearing
wires it's safe and easy
oh my gosh i've gotten so many terrible
like wire rashes around the neck or
like just major bruises because it hurts
because all your weight like
especially if somebody's pulling you or
it's an aggressive motion and it's
connected to your body and it's like oh
so it'll just pull against all your skin
or whatever you're wearing so it can
definitely be painful sometimes
the camera angles everything is so good
it is so good so one of the key rules of
filmmaking is the 180 degree rule
basically if on your frame one person's
on frame left one person's on frame
right
if you go to the other side of that line
between them suddenly they flip sides
and one person's now on frame right that
was previously on frame left it gets
really confusing
especially in fight scenes the problem
is sometimes in fight scenes
moves read better from one side than the
other so you need to get back and forth
across the lines
lazy filmmakers will just jump the line
talented filmmakers like the wachowskis
will make a point of using shots in
between the 180 degree
jumps to hide that jump or let you flow
naturally so for example
or is on the left boom cut to the foot
shot
okay we did the jump we use the spin to
motivate the jump we're offline now
morpheus on the right so
we jump the line but we jump the line by
cutting into the foot catch and the spin
which are filmed on the line letting us
then jump to the other side not feel
like the actors have just suddenly
switched places
so they're giving us a full 360 and the
camera's moving all over the place but
we're never getting lost
because the wachowskis have mapped out
their camera shots specifically to give
us those transition beats
it's all very subtle it just happens you
don't think about it but suddenly you
have a fight and it feels alive you have
camera work that feels alive and it all
flows
and they've done that puzzle behind the
scenes to make sure that everything
locks into place
one of the best fights ever seriously
i don't believe it
what is this movie this is above the law
i think it also has another title
corey uen directed this that's jimmy's
uncle
wait jimmy wong freddie and jimmy wong
oh what
that's i guess this is their uncle let
me call him real quick
jimbo hey man hey what's up i want to
confirm something with you
so there's a movie called above the law
is did your uncle direct this movie
is it corey yuan yeah yeah that's a yes
your uncle directed this movie what the
heck he
uh went to the same opera school almost
the same class as jackie chan young
everyone that has the last name yen took
it because they did it in honor of their
master
huh that is nuts dude all right hey
jimmy i appreciate that man thanks for
clearing that one up
okay talk soon all right love you bye
all right so i guess this is jimmy
wong's slash freddie wong's
uncle's movie
damn that was cool that's so cool is
that the fastest way down
for sure ow right there
would be so painful what the heck how do
you not hurt yourself right
i mean that's pretty rough
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah he doesn't even bother with the wig
at a certain point just blatant face
opened a camera in slow motion boom
what did he land on or sure yeah he
right there is there a pad that's
out of frame because of the stairs oh
it's gotta be yeah like you can't see
the ground right are they on wires
it's gotta be wires it looks like a wire
to me does it
there's a little float i feel like
that's gotta be a wire you're right
crazy
that was was that just another chinese
guy
he's a random chinese dude
that's so impressive is he doing that it
looks like it
wait it's reversed you think so yeah
wait what that's so smart
you're right it's reversed ruining the
magic one shot at a time
oh that is cool like that didn't look
like it had any wire assist it looked
like somebody just jumped backwards and
landed like that
i think this choreography is so creative
with the
the chain whip and the poles there's so
many like moments of detail put into
getting their reactions
yeah if you think of fight scenes all
just getting cool moves but it's like
you need to really find your times to
get your acting in
dang right into a coffin
all right thanks jimmy's dad i mean
i was like thanks jimmy's uncle i go
that way you go this way yes
okay
this is a full-on brush so much
[Music]
oh look at the camera look at the camera
go back
perfectly look at the camera work look
how perfect this is
that's so so good dude if this is anyone
else
they're gonna go he's gonna go into the
kip up and then they're gonna cut and
it's gonna do the kip up
and then they're gonna land and then
they keep going but he keeps it in one
shot
and he keeps going the timing of that
too it's just like so i remember jackie
chan talking about how they have like
sounds like you know
they do the fight sounds where they're
using them for cues it's like when a
guy's gonna approach and start his
combination from the side he'll give a
certain shout
that cues jackie that he's coming and so
they're probably doing the same thing
here jackie probably gives a cue and he
hits the ground
and those guys didn't give a cue when
the push is going to happen so jackie
starts his kip
and it's all just hidden as i'm going if
you guys
want to see how jackie chan does all of
his stuff look up jackie chan my stunts
it is a full-on like two-hour breakdown
of jackie
telling you all of his secrets and he he
choreographs the fight scene with you
and it's the best thing ever it's the
best
it's crazy how much of their stunt work
is just the same scrappy tricks
that you have to do when you're just
trying to make your own like homemade
fight scenes
i think there's a moment in jackie chan
my stunts where he talks about
how anyone can do what he's doing you
just have to
like have the dedication and rep it out
just keep doing all your takes you just
gotta
keep doing it like it takes me forever
it's gonna take you forever but
you just have to dedicate your time to
whatever you're doing speaking of doing
a take a million times remember that
scene in
the first spider-man
wow they did that for real it took him
like 140 tries
yeah yeah they literally just dropped
everything and he caught it all in the
tray
and then in that moment they were both
like holy [ __ ]
yeah yeah like we really didn't how does
the apple land like that it doesn't roll
do they have sticky stuff on the bottom
right you can see how sticky everything
is
everything is sticky imagine if you were
out of focus for that one shot
you're fired anybody can do it don't
have to be jackie chan
you just need a lot of film and a lot of
time
no wonder you man
no one knew man that's so good
man i love that was that chris tucker
doing the flip or is that a stunt double
that's probably stunt double and how
cool would it be to be chris tucker's
character in this where it's like you
just get to be a guy who's not
particularly good at stunts
just jackie chan is your mentor and then
you would film a whole movie with them
yeah be amazing yeah rush hour two well
rush hour one is like
nine out of ten and the rush hour two is
a ten ten yeah and it's rare that the
second one's better than the first one
all right yo guys all right this is the
dream okay here's what you need to do
hit up jackie chan chances are one of
you know jackie and let him know
we're we're putting out the jackie sign
the bat signal okay
we want him on the show we'd reach final
form if jackie came down
we'd love to talk with jackie and hear
about everything i mean we'll just let
jackie we don't need
clips i'll just take it over the
internet too if he just wants to be on
the
on the camera on the internet and that's
all we get totally fine i'll take
whatever
if we can get jackie chan on the show
i'll stop asking you to subscribe
that's big will you subscribe already
what are you doing
thank you hey everybody this video is
sponsored by raycon so i'm here to talk
about the everyday e25 earbuds
raycon is disrupting the electronics
industry by designing premium wireless
audio for half the price without
compromise
raycon earbuds give you seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and a more
compact design come in this handy little
carrying case that charges the earbuds
and the earbuds themselves have six
hours of battery life it's snuggly in
your ear the noise isolating and you can
even use them to take phone calls they
come in a variety of colors you can pick
something that matches your wardrobe
with a variety of fit options and no
dangling wires or stems
plus raycon has a 45 day free return
policy
if you guys are in the market for a nice
little wireless pair of bluetooth
earbuds
check out raycon's you can go to the
link in the description below buy
raycon.com
quarter crew to get 15 off of an order
of the raycon
everyday e25 earbuds check them out
amy thank you so much for joining us on
the show you're easily one of those most
legit stunt women i know so to have you
here is
an honor and a privilege and i'm so glad
that you're willing to share your
insights and knowledge with everyone who
watches god guys that was a really nice
moment i'm honored to be here thank you
i really appreciate that and if you guys
want to see more of amy's stuff you
should really check out her instagram
amy e johnston there's a link in the
description below she also has a youtube
channel where she posts a bunch of stuff
as well but
really cool behind the scenes snippets
martial arts all this really great stuff
thanks for watching everybody see you
next saturday get jackie
get jackie